or OPEC headquarters abandoned in Vienna
instead the group in its allies met
virtually remotely agreeing to cut
global oil production by the largest
amount in history 10 million barrels a
day that's about a 10% reduction
oil-producing nations agree to the cut
last week Mexico wouldn't sign refusing
to drop its output so low President
Trump
weighed in the United States in
discussions last night with Mexico
Saudi Arabia Russia and in dealing with
OPEC nations we are trying to get Mexico
as the expression goes over the barrel
Trump then offered to reduce US
production further to make up for Mexico
conscious that lower oil prices could be
terminal for America's shale industry he
tweeted Sunday the big oil deal with
OPEC plus is done this will save
hundreds of thousands of energy jobs in
the United States there are 10 million
jobs associated with the shale industry
in the United States and that's a huge
constituency for president Trump present
Trump doesn't need any more job losses
in the last three weeks alone we've seen
17 million jobs lost because of the
pandemic global demand for oil has
evaporated by around 30 percent due to
covert 19 planes are grounded streets
deserted and just as the virus forced
entire nations into hibernation Saudi
Arabia exacerbated the imbalance ramping
up its oil output in a bid to knock its
pitch our rival Russia out of the market
the glut seemed us benchmark West Texas
Intermediate plummeting from sixty three
dollars a barrel in January to $20 a
barrel and late March and more than two
decades oh we see this as really a
monumental achievement I mean if you had
told us a week and a half ago that's
Saudi Arabia Russia and the United
States we're going to come together to
forge an agreement to cut 10 million
barrels a day and
even more from the market I think most
people would not really believed it but
pulling prices back to profitability may
still be many months off even with the
biggest oil cut in history is still an
oversupply well the numbers are eye
popping the decrease is is perhaps not
enough and when the outlines of this
deal was announced on Thursday after an
initial spike prices actually fell
produces banking that if countries stick
to the deal oil will be back as a wanted
commodity in 2021
Charlotte Bella's al Jazeera Alejandra
Barbarossa is vice president of crude
for albus media a price reporting agency
for the energy industry joins us live
from Tokyo good to have you with us sir
so first of all do you think this climb
in prices is gonna last when it
continued if we consider that oil that
oil inventories are gonna keep rising
because the OPEC cuts are smaller than
you know just a third of the actual drop
in demand that we've seen as a result of
the pandemic actually we should expect
prices to resume their drop quite
swiftly into the second quarter
potentially sending the price of WTI
down to $10 per barrel or even lower
which is the price at which the US
production and the shale producers in
Texas and New Mexico are actually forced
to cut down output because it's no
longer profitable to keep pumping at
those prices because it's below their
operating costs alright there's a lot in
your answer though to unpack let me
start with will this at the very least
then put a floor under the the price
crash and given what you've said is that
$10 a barrel now what we're looking at
instead of the previous forecast which
is saying well they could even go into -
it's likely that the Brent price Brent
representing the benchmark for prices in
Europe and and somehow the Middle East
as well
connected to Dubai price that that will
not fall as much but the price of WTI
as the benchmark for US production which
affects the economics of the shale patch
in the US will have to drop
significantly to trigger those
production cuts because otherwise oil is
going to keep flowing and within the
absence of any significant recovery in
demand storage may be full by the end of
May so before then we we have to see
that deep contraction in prices to make
about the number that Alejandra you can
put a number on it for me what what is
the floor right now that we're looking
at well a potentially $10 per barrel for
WTI all right will this deal hold
together a lot of people were dragged to
it kind of kicking and screaming
what if coronavirus notion to like four
months six months is you know some of
the really worst case scenarios predict
just a month ago in the previous OPEC
meeting Russia walked away because it
didn't want to cut two hundred or three
hundred thousand barrels per day now
Russia has committed to cut ten times as
much
two and a half million barrels per day
there's a lot of skepticism that the
Russian government might unify all the
individual independent private producers
to cap their production to achieve those
two point five million barrels per day
so there's a lot of there are lots of
questions about whether that oil will
actually be taken out of the market and
whether compliance will even reach the
50% that was reached in the initial
stages of the previous OPEC cut all
right thank you very much
Alejandro Barba hasta that thank you